thank you very much Hannah thanks to all
of you for coming out and our discussion
tonight is on Europe on the edge and I
must hasten to say that when the notion
of this debate was put together many of
the events that now form the context for
our conversation had obviously not
happened and one of those is the calling
of a general election which was called
and summoned to be the brexit election
and some of you may have been struck by
the absence of discussion of Europe and
breaks it in this election and so not
for the first time intelligence squared
aims to deliver what the politicians and
others will not which is a candid
conversation about Europe which has been
missing from this campaign but obviously
the other part of context are the
attacks in London
on Saturday night and the attacks two
weeks before in Manchester and they will
inevitably I think framed some part of
our conversation and of course just by
all of you being here
and mr. BAE going ahead is I think a
sign that of art collective
determination to defy those who would
stop us having these conversations and
instead to keep on so and that's I'm
going to say more about the context as
we get into it but and I want next to
really just having said something about
the moment we're in to say a few words
about each of the people because each of
them do come to these topics with a
particular expertise
despite Michael Gove saying we've had
enough of experts we can never get
enough of experts here and so we have
assembled here five people all with a
unique vantage point and tremendous
expertise on our topics that you know
and there are different ones that might
lead to Europe being on the edge so let
me introduce them more or less in
physical order professor of economics at
Oxford and development expert who is
widely acknowledged as an expert in the
field and acclaim for his new book
refuge he
recently turned his attention as that
title suggests to the subject of mass
migration examining its effect on both
the societies that receive migrants and
on the countries those migrants leave
behind a warm welcome please for
professor Paul Collier
[Applause]
our next speaker is an award-winning
novelist and is the most widely read
female writer in her native Turkey she's
a prominent advocate for minority rights
and free speech there and elsewhere you
may have read her nonfiction worker
essays in the Financial Times The New
York Times The New Yorker and The
Guardian
welcome please for Elise shut up
thank you our next speaker on my
immediate right is born in was born in
Italy and is now the professor of
finance at the University of Chicago
Booth School of Business he writes
frequently on populism which is
obviously I think going to be one of our
themes tonight immigration and the state
of the eurozone economy he recently
launched a heated debate in the Italian
media about the costs and the benefits
of the euro for his native Italy he is
Luigi Zingales and turning to our
speakers who have hot-footed it from the
continent to be here born in Belgium
that a journalist who became
editor-in-chief of the French weekly
newsmagazine L'Express she now presents
a current affairs programme on Frances
equivalent of BBC four she is
christinauk rent
[Applause]
and completing our panel known to many
of you I'm sure he is a regular writer
and columnist for both The Spectator and
standpoint magazine writes frequently so
all kinds of other publications
including the Sunday Times here in The
Wall Street Journal in the United States
his current and new book is the strange
death of Europe immigration identity and
Islam which has now I think this week
reached the number-one spot in the
Sunday Times bestsellers list he is
Douglas Murray
so that is our panel and we are talking
as I said about Europe on the edge
that's the subject before us and I'm
guessing that you could carry or hold
that thought in your mind applying to
many things you could be thinking of the
terror attacks that we've experienced in
Britain in these last few weeks but our
neighbors on the continent have been
experiencing in recent months - you
could be thinking about the economy you
could be thinking about the phenomenon
of mass migration so I'm going to ask
each of our contributors here to set out
their stool and tell us really in just a
minute also what it is that is making
them anxious and what - what are they
worried about and what makes them feel
that Europe is on the edge and why don't
I start with you Christina Craig well
I'm actually worried that so many
brilliant minds still dwell in to gloom
and doom at a time where it seems to me
Europe is in a much better shape than it
was a few months ago there is that fatal
triangle mr. trumpet in a toga they
compel us to really do our things
ourselves there's also a better economic
cycle in the eurozone and last but not
least the populist wave seems to have
been stopped somehow certainly in
Holland and certainly in France where
Emanuel McCoy I think will reverberate
and stimulate a much more positive
approach to European issues and assembly
elections coming up in France this we
have a Don June 11 and June 80 so it's
not all about us when it comes to
elections there are other elections
going on - Thank You Christine why don't
we hear from you Paul Collier on what's
on your mind in terms of what makes you
worried about Europe on the edge when I
see Europe as a political project
primarily a little project by the
Germans French which some years ago made
it catastrophic mistake
of using economic instruments as
political symbols and I think I was
catastrophic because it produced
powerful economic diversions and that
potentially gives an incentive for some
countries to leave em and I think the
Germans have already made it pretty
clear that their strategy for stopping
any exit is to make British exit as
painful as possible
so actually I'm fearful for the
implications of that strategy for us so
in order to discourage other people from
leaving and spreading the contagion
there will be a sort of this is the
punishment beatings model yeah in which
Britain gets cake face punishment its
reparations are back interesting you've
already broken the unspoken rule of all
these discussions which is never to
mention the war you've done it within
four or so minutes but somebody was
going to do let's hear from you next
Luigi Zingales about what do you think
what do you have on your mind what's
worrying you so I'm worried that Europe
which was a in its origin a fantastic
project to bring prosperity and harmony
in Europe exactly turning into a prison
where people start to build resentments
and hate each other more in 20 years ago
the Greeks were not calling the German
Nazi and the Germans were not calling
the Greeks lazy and today this is an
outcome of a ill-conceived economic
project that as Paul said was conceived
by politicians for politicians means use
economic means in the wrong direction
and unfold early has been sold and
supported by a lot of economies but so
far with pretty negative consequences I
don't see an end inside and I'm sorry I
don't think that a thermicon as a magic
one to fix it this I mentioned at the
start you've kicked off this debate
about the euro
is it you okay argument that Italy
itself should come out of the Europe I
think that is a bit like Hotel
California you can check out but never
leave I think that it's a design to
destroy a country if it leaves so it's
impossible to leave at least
unilaterally but some nations and mine
is one suffers tremendously any that
that's the that's a dilemma and when you
force people into a cage you know you
have range and that's what is happening
so we've had to very pessimistic views
from this time we had an optimistic view
from Christine early for you on this
what's worrying you if anything about
you I don't think you should expect an
optimistic view from a Turkish writer we
are so so depressed but honestly coming
from a country like Turkey where
diversity cosmopolitanism has been lost
and the cost of that loss has been
tremendous I am worried about many
things in Europe and across the world I
think what has happened in Turkey could
happen anywhere it could even happen
here and while it's true that populism
populist pride seem to have slows they
have not disappeared they are there and
we need to talk about them
and to me it's very interesting to see
when populist movements are in
opposition they have an impact beyond
their size so much so that they can
change the rhetoric of mainstream
politics and politicians we have seen an
example of this in the Netherlands for
instance yes here two others did not win
the elections but thanks to his presence
and his base mainstream politicians in
the Netherlands started to employ a much
more nationalistic jingoistic language
during their elections now when populist
come to power this is when they are in a
position they have an impact beyond
their size when they come to power these
three has shown us that they benefit
enormous ly from controlling the state
of virata's the main narrative but also
the media and thirdly I think we need to
be careful because no matter how
isolationist and nationalistic they
might sound they are connected they are
interrelated we all are
so today's populist movements encourage
each other so yes trump's existence also
encourages alderaan and vice-versa
and therefore I think we need to
understand that we're all in this
together we have things to worry about
to feel hopeful about as well but the
danger of nationalism tribalism has not
disappeared and all around the world we
are being told that we all belong in our
tribes and they're telling us that if we
go back to our tribes we will be safer
if we're surrounded by things and that's
an illusion thank you I want to come
back to populism straight after but why
don't we hear from you dougies you've
written a whole book about the death and
strange death of Europe you obviously
believe Europe is not just on the edge
but has gone over the edge
just tell us in a very distilled form if
you can what's on your mind sure I don't
make any apologies for being gloomy I
think that if the facts that gloomy you
should be gloomy and I think a huge
amount of damage has been done
historically and is still being done
today by optimists but we might get on
to that my view is that I mean that our
continent is in the business of bullets
dodging these days and every time a
bullets sort of whizzes past its head we
think oh well it hasn't hit so it will
be fine for another day and I think that
isn't true but I think that the real
problems of far deeper than the issues
that any one election throws up to these
days or any one challenger can throw up
my books about what I see as being the
two twin challenges that have come
simultaneously are the first is the mass
movement of people's into Europe and the
second is that this should come at the
same time that Europeans have lost the
sense of what we are or what we meant to
be or whether we're allowed to be or
whether we are just the place where
anyone in the world who wants to call
our continent home can call it home and
I think this is a massive historical
issue that far beyond at the moment the
grasp of any politicians in our country
to deal with but it'll it'll be the one
that gals and
as I think throughout our lives and
instead of Europe having a philosophy in
which which says if you're here then
you're European and you can call
yourself and think of yourself of being
at home what do you think should be the
approach instead well it would start by
recognizing that it isn't the case that
anyone in the world who walks into
Europe immediately becomes a European
our historical reasons for getting to
some of the ideas we have about
separation of church and state about our
wounded asked you towards religion our
attitudes towards politics in my view
are highly unlikely to just be picked up
and arrived at exactly the same moment
as we're at by millions of people coming
into our continent and I think that all
of our political leaders massively
underestimated this and it may well be
impossible to reverse that we're also
going to have to come back to that and
you're going to want to make a defense
of Chris Christine you're going to make
one to want to make a defensive optimism
yes I think I'm going to see rather
lonely no not necessarily
I'm sure there's also optimist out there
let's let's just pick up this thing
about populism first because you
suggested that in a way the moment had
passed the type that peak had been
reached because micron 1 in so lepen but
I thought before we get into you
mentioned populism to a leaf why don't
we just say how we're defining it first
of all just you know in a very short
just away what do you mean when you say
popular well that's the challenge isn't
it because it's so close to democracy
and we're not talking about a problem
that originates from outside democracy
but comes from within and and shows us
the fragility of democracy in other
words how they deal with movements that
come to power using the means of
democracy and once they consolidate
their power use that position in order
to suppress all voices of dissent one by
one the other one would be a classic a
yeah so teach the Turkish case is quite
interesting and it really holds the
important examples for Democrats and in
my opinion progressives liberals all
around the world
populism needs dualities I think that is
one of the keys there always has to be
on us and there needs to be of them the
description of them can change from time
to time but that duality is essential it
also tells us that there's a real people
pure people versus the corrupt elite and
it presents itself as if it has nothing
to do with the establishment as if it
has been assumed from another planet
nothing can convince me that Trump is
not part of the financial establishment
or morena fan herself is not part of the
political elite of course we can be
critical of the elites mistakes but let
us not make the mistake of thinking that
these populist demagogues are themselves
not part of daily excellent thank you so
that's an understanding what popular
populism is Paul Collier what what role
has migration and the backlash against
migration played in fueling these
populist movements visible actually in
Britain with you kid but in France with
the pen and hollands and filters there's
all kinds of examples well how much is
this about immigration I think um and
most in the audience won't like this but
I think what was actually happened is is
is is not particularly something to the
let's focus on the English working class
and the English working class now is
more or less where it's always being I
think what walked is the English middle
class and which is decided that it
doesn't really want to be English it's
walk away from a shared identity with
ordinary people and I think this is
particularly pronounced in London I'm
afraid I grew up in Sheffield right with
a proper place and and I grew up in an
environment that I was surrounded by
Scots
left right across the road all Scots
and it never occurred to any of us that
we were other than the same identity
they were Scottish lollies English but
we're all British which is fourth
together God have done it again and and
because of that there was a strong
willingness to the fortunate to
redistribute to the less fortunate
we were shared identity and I think that
that has gradually corroded now I think
the where does immigration fail to this
it's a bit marginal it's something that
the upper middle class gets very excited
about because it can accuse ordinary
people of being racist right but the
here's here's an uncomfortable piece of
statistical evidence right across Europe
the higher the proportion of immigrants
in the population the lower is the
willingness of those above median income
to make tax transfers to people below
median income that's across Europe
there's also an experimental behavioral
evidence which which explains why right
is I can't go into it but and what that
means is people below median income
ordinary people have a perfectly
rational reason to fear that immigration
will sort of weaken this sense of shared
bonds and the middle class will just run
off go into it same thing and so sort of
distribution of redistribution of wealth
and and the base the basic sort of
fundament fundamentals of social
democracy rest in your view on there
being a degree of homogeneity in a
society but once it's too diverse this
is an argument that you and has others
that may want attitude of earth in the
moat the willingness to share becomes it
has to be a shared identity that doesn't
mean I'm a genius
ethnic identity or anything like that it
just means a sense of buying into we are
all the only basis viable basis for
shared identity you can't buy in on a
set of values because our values in a in
a democratic open society our values are
all over the place right the one thing
you can all agree on is is location
we're all British we all live in the
place
and so you need that to become an
important salient feature of identity so
you will have heard arguments like that
in farms as well the French equivalent
arguments but now the country has
changed it's so diverse that the
willingness to treat each other as
neighbors is less perhaps and this is
part of what's been driving I will put
it slightly different clear from Paul
without of course denying his argument
but it's pretty obvious that all over
the continent the middle class has been
struck by two phenomenons one is
globalization and the other is the the
technological revolution which means
that people get to be more and more
individualistic and they approach to
their political institutions very
political elites media elites business
business elites they become very
different but I think that this idea of
a loss of identity is quite this thing
from actual migrations they've been
migrations in Europe throughout our
history dating back centuries it's more
the refugee crisis which has helped
populist throughout Europe to say oh
we're losing our identity and of course
in places where they have never seen one
single immigrant or one single refugee
in France we saw that we have you know
not in the been saying oh you know where
has France gone but at the street yeah
well she did well in areas where they
were not refugees but that that's been
the case you know throughout Europe you
don't need to have foreigners to to be
exact fabric there's a case in Slovakia
in a place run actually by a neo-nazi of
an Erasmus student who was just stabbed
because he happens to be black so I
think this notion of identity has indeed
many more ingredients to it than just
the refugee crisis and I think there's
always that ambiguity between
the refugee crisis on one hand and the
migration is
you on the Eldar police yes the issue of
identity with the emphasis on the
singularity of it I think it's so
crucial in in all populist movements of
course we are talking about very
different examples you can't we have
populism sin well for Sweden but also we
have focusing in crisis-ridden Greece
there are differences but this is one of
the common areas populism doesn't like
plurality multiplicity and at the end of
the day all populist movements expect us
to clarify a single monolithic identity
are you a Muslim being Muslim according
to my definition of Islam are you a
Dutch
you can only be done she can't book
little which is completely against our
nature because as human beings who are
made of water we have multiple multiple
belongings so that that is a repetitive
you know example that we see from from
country to they want to another Douglas
I want to hear what you say to
Christine's point about there's always
been waves of immigration it's just part
of European history why now is it's
making you big fear that actually Europe
itself may be even on the verge of its
own death because of the this change
that you discern in your book and in
what you've been writing first of all
and the point that Christine makes does
not prove the cases cause does it
because a lot of the areas where people
don't like the diversity shall we say is
because they've had enough of the
diversity it's not because they've never
tried it they've tried it and don't like
it and they go to areas where they can
not have more of it for and down their
throat and that's one of the big issues
isn't that everyone who's afforded as it
were endless diversity as a definition
of us will always come to is is there a
moment when there is such a thing as too
much and I think that the people can
sense that and certainly sense it far
better than any political or other class
this word by the way populism and
populist I don't buy it myself I don't
use it I think populist is a term that
some people use for things they don't
like it
it's simply a really good and easy way I
mean let me give you an example
Monsieur macron ran without a party if a
tree was formed his own movement was a
one-man show very charismatic and so on
he's not described as a populist why
when Hillary Clinton does the US and
them with Wall Street as she did in her
campaign boasting that she was the only
candidate so tough on Wall Street that
they actually were fighting against her
who describes Hillary Clinton as a
populist if Hillary Clinton had won the
election would it have been a populist
win if remain had one would any of one
have said this is a populist saying no
it's un frightening it's a bottling is
half I mean supporters know I mean she's
the head of the conservative here a
definition you heard a definition from a
leaf earlier which was when it picked
itself again to the elite it says we're
the real people real thing well people
against a foreigner leaf or a distance a
lead and particularly I'm just giving
you a leafs definition if it uses the
techniques of democracy to in some way
once it has power to either suppress or
just restrain democracy and democratic
norms first of all the idea of us and
then is a derogatory way of describing
what their liberal Dutch novelist paul
shaffer described when he said in order
to make this work we're going to need a
we we need a we we need a first person
plural to describe ourselves as a
society and that is just another way of
saying oh you're just doing us and then
what you do need and us you do need an
us and and as I say I return to what if
it is the case I leave a point that one
of the few definitions or the bits of a
definition I would I could find
agreement with is this thing of as they
were overstating the power of elites and
overstating your own you know nascent
ability to connect with with the people
and so on well five it's sometimes you
know people aren't on to nothing if you
were to describe a sort of incredibly
disjointed unelected you know far-far
high above the people and unaccountable
to them saying you know what could you
do better than come up with the European
Commission is it always popular
is it is it always populous to point
that out I would say no so sometimes
people are onto something but as I said
this is I think this is just another way
of saying scare quotes around these
people we we would like to call them
racist but we're not sure it will work
anymore
and winner versus so we'll call them
populist lots of people want to come in
thank you
both of you want to come in I just want
to ask you Luigi about your take on that
is because what has whether or not you
accept the definition of either as there
are two debaters on this point a lot of
people debate quest discuss what is
driving populism is it cultural anxiety
broadly defined meaning the questions of
identity and who is asked and perhaps
race or is it just more simply economic
hardship and pain Christine mentioned
globalization other people have talked
about automation you know people who are
left behind economically that's why they
are turning to so-called we make that
Douglass's war is so-called populism so
two things first of all in the I like
the definition but there's a part
missing is the other side the other side
of populist is elitist and I think that
the two are very symbiotic because you
can have populist only when there is
elite that is elitist and the other is
justify being elegance because they are
populist and vice versa
and I think that there's not enough
discussion these days or groups that are
elite and as contact tower ordinary
people when illrick law calls deplorable
the people who vote for Trump
she's not an elitist when throughout
Europe they say oh you have to redo the
referendum in England because the
outcome is not the right one and we keep
going until we get the right outcome or
even sort of a debate whether you should
a universal suffrage because the people
don't understand because we're smart and
understand and they don't I think that's
all it is and I think this eldest is
very pervasive I don't know enough about
the UK but I can tell you in the United
States and in Italy is very pervasive
and I think that's part of the problem
and pilot Rob is really is to separate
from the rest of the people in a sense
social mobility even the United States
has gone down tremendously and you end
up interacting only with some kind of
people in the shocking thing how many
friends do you have in the States water
for Trump is very rare to find that and
gee they were not 50% it was only 48 but
they're 48 percent of the population
where are they that then shows how
separate from the rest of the people we
live and our elytis we are good so
partly you can't have populism without
elitism where are you on this question
of whether or not that populist move has
Ria's peaked because in in France they
just elected in huge numbers a very
elitist figure in the form of Emmanuel
macron there was no anti a leaders and
there they were quite happy to embrace
him as the new president does it mean
the feeling you're describing has passed
I don't think so I am on the side of
people think that the primary cause is
economical and so I think that this is
not going away anytime soon I would be
more interested in studying whether
France is an exception maybe because
they're more a middle class and so that
that's a reason why they did not fall so
much into that as other places or so
they would not have left behind as left
behind and also outraged but considering
a victory the fact that a fascist leader
got 35% of the vote sorry if those are
the victories I don't look forward to
defeat yes and genu well I know you want
to get on a poll is in waiting for more
than le video this with Mike on I mean
he faced a Marxist a fascist and a crook
and just leap and he has a breakthrough
by 3% and then look at our first round
yeah yeah that's and then of course in
case of hecka clashes because he went
that is not a resounding victory I'm
sorry it's not right and he donkey could
have won against that and
and the is not want to be reduce badly
need to be rude about donkeys and well
the where Leo killed your next point
yeah now the what I wanted to say was
that incidentally I entirely agree that
the implication of this is the elites
have walked off it's not the populist
have done something weird the elites of
all comes now there are I want to make a
distinction two sorts of nationalism
there's the nationalism that I grew up
with in Sheffield we were all British
why not because of any ethnicity or
something we all lived in the same
country and we were proud of that the
nationalism that the populist generate
is a very different animal they're not
actually saying we're all a country
they're saying we're the country and
you're not and that's a very different
thing that there's an inclusive
nationalism there I grew up with and
there's an exclusive claiming of a
national label by one group or another
and that we've got to oppose that the
root of fascism but the idea that to
oppose fascism we have to just say oh
we're all global citizens is nothing
else is crazy
we need shared identity in order to be
generous and be cooperative very helpful
so exclusive nationalism is the
nationalism you're against I would think
you mean marine lepen would be an
example of that in Britain would you say
you kit expresses that exclusive or not
yes yeah you were yes okay it's
clarified and Christine Christine wants
to come back and then we must affirm
Olivia well after this phrase of
Britishness all I can try and say that
France has gone through an extraordinary
presidential campaign where indeed the
diversity of opinions the violence in
the political climate and indeed the way
citizens have engaged and have indeed
given not to a donkey I'm sorry but to a
young man who was extremely visionary in
the way he took advantage of these
extraordinary circumstances the turnout
was very high he won by a very wide
margin the first round and wider margin
the second round
so I think all these ironical comments
about the fact that anybody including a
donkey might have won is out of place we
have a presidential system with a
three-round election and indeed we will
see again in June for the parliamentary
elections if that young man who ran
without the political party has been
able to build a political button which
is it I think a very good omen to the
capacity of our European democracies not
to be as tired as they are supposed to
be and indeed to be able to renew their
elites
their political age and indeed again
rejuvenate our citizen just respond to
be necessarily positive the region just
respond to Luigi's point though which is
yes good in my country very well we all
know that but it's not that encouraging
that a fascist his word like marine
lepen took whole as much as she did that
is actually trouble
yes indeed that's precisely because of
what Paul said that all these there was
an extreme left an extreme right and
conservatives candidate who turned out
to be if not a crook at least to be how
could I put it a very callous about
public money but this interposer project
about marketing at one point I don't
agree Holland is a typical case in point
that Holland is a very prosperous
country and yet it still has a far right
so it's not always economic reasons
which account for quote-unquote
populations yeah thank you and that's to
well and some of the more affluent parts
of the United States voted for Trump as
well so we can come back to that let le
if you be wanting to get in I also want
to make sure that you know that we are
going to talk about terrorism as an
issue for Europe and I don't want to
hear you le a new Douglas and then we're
going to go on to terrorism I mean first
the emphasis on shared values I think
it's incredibly important for many of my
British friends friends the the entire
EU debate was a primarily financial
economic debate for us those of us to
come from the periphery of Europe for us
it's mainly a debate on shared values
and the danger of losing those shared
values and the importance of having a
supranational umbrella that brings
people from different backgrounds around
shared values to me is very important I
do not think that nationalism of any
kind can be inclusive when we have to
make a difference between maybe
nationalism and patriotism it is
perfectly okay understandable and
beautiful for us to have emotional
attachments to the cultures lands
families where we come from but
nationalism as an ideology is a very
dangerous thing and again people coming
from Turkey the Middle East the Balkans
we have seen the dangers of all of that
with regards to populism
with regards to populism populist are
not the reason why we are in this mess
they are there because there has been a
mess in the first place so it is the
outcome of democracy in trouble it is
the outcome of a crisis we do have a
crisis that we need to talk about and I
do not think that that crisis can solely
be understood by looking at economic or
financial inequality by no means I'm not
belittling under estimating the
importance of economic gaps but we need
to talk about other things as well
particularly emotions which has been so
underestimated in mainstream political
theory but I do believe that this is the
age of anxiety and anger
it is perfectly understandable for
people to worry whether their children
are going to find the job you know it's
perfectly understandable that the people
are worried that yes there will be too
many refugees and I plan to be worried
about terrorism if we do not allow them
to speak their anxiety to talk about it
if we don't have open spaces and judge
them on the basis of their emotions I
think we will be pushing them towards
the far-right it's to me it's very
interesting to see let's go back a few
years we have the Arab Spring we have
the financial crisis we have the euro
crisis break the Trump many times
including the polls the experts got
things wrong we need to talk about these
things how is it possible but where we
are right now is many populist
demagogues and I think we need to use
this word they are saying to the people
you know what these people they elite
they're always getting it wrong and you
are the pure people you just need to
trust your gods your instincts you don't
need these intellectuals here so the
denigration of the intellect to me is a
very dangerous trend one more thing I
want to add I would let lots of time
because that's what we must remove it
off
you will have all done let I want to
make the transition to talk about
terrorism because it's obviously in our
minds in this city this now and we you
know then I want to open it up so I want
to hear you're different you know we've
talked about populism and what might be
driving that and what might define it
but Douglas I know you wanted to get on
the other thing but if you can let's
pivot to this issue and everyone is
asking was the game the same question
which is what is causing this and is
this something that is visit merely
visited upon Europe or is this something
that on some level has been caused by
decisions Europe and Europeans have
taken well firstly let me just say that
the there is a narrative we've heard a
little bit of it so far that the
public's of Europe are being led astray
by talented demagogues it's possible as
well that the public's of Europe have
seen a political class fail to get a
grasp of very major things or even talk
about them and the public have noticed
fact and that it's not that there's a
meta-narrative that's going around they
were just facts there are things that we
can see with our eyes there are things
that clear to us which politicians dint
tread on and I've had this experience
throughout throughout my life I never
forget the time many years ago I think
when France first banned the headscarf
I've told this story before the Labour
MP Annan in a studio with me discussing
that the rights and wrongs of this and
spent the whole time with me an Iranian
friend of mine was also there explaining
why we were fascist and Islamophobic and
so on for defending the French
Republic's verdict on the headscarf and
we came out in this Labour MP patted me
on the back and said never forget
Douglas we're all with you and I said
well what was that all about on air you
know which was a more pertinent moment
and he said look I've got a large Muslim
constituency and I can't do anything in
this area and that's that's what you
hear all the time in private and the
politicians when I say this to them
their eyes go huge they dent the tread
onto this but there's a very
straightforward fact I'm afraid on this
terrorism thing this has to be
confronted extremism
and violence can come from absolutely
any community pretty much an even
Buddhists you know when riled up in
certain parts of the world it can become
violent
the Quakers I think we can't go for but
but but pretty much everything he said
was I accept that this is not a
something to be picked up on but Islamic
extremism only comes from the Islamic
religion and from followers of it and
that is an imported problem for Europe
that's that's a problem that we brought
in and we're now facing and none of our
politicians by the way I'm not there's
no great conspiracy about this nobody
expected it if you just said to a
politician in the 1990s in the earlier
years of the 2000s Europe is going to be
wracked by blasphemy debates it said
what are you talking about when did the
Spanish Inquisition return and then we
all became used to it that there were
certain things you couldn't do that were
actually blasphemy in a country like
this and were punishable by effectively
by death by a death sentence we all
accepted that and now we're told we have
to accept the terrorism
well maybe we do have to accept the
terrorism as part of our life but the
public's have a right to be looking at
the politicians and saying look this is
a problem you brought in it's not only
it's not only to be talked about it's
not only to be talked about as a problem
but unless we're willing to do that bit
of identifying to my mind the gap
between what the public can see and what
the public know and what the political
class is even willing to whisper will
continue to grow and that's the gap
where you have to worry so who wants to
take on what
Douglas is that Chris Christine you come
back on it I would like to add another
comment I'm not disputing that this this
time around I won't hear from somebody
who does very so it's interesting that
in France we've had this very critical
approach of the British view about
multiculturalism community RISM which in
our vocabulary are really bad words and
there has been a great deal of French
self delusion about the idea that our
secular culture would actually integrate
rather than assimilate and that indeed
our second or third generation of
immigrants coming from former colonies
which is also the case I believe in this
country would naturally believe that
aesthetics over central dialects was
their ancestors and that our education
system would transfer them it has worked
to a point especially with girls but
also than with young men but we we have
discovered and indeed as we all know
France has been struck by terrorism
homegrown terrorism French citizens most
of the time as indeed British citizens
in this case and so it shows that for
two or three generations not only our
politicians but our societies have not
really measured the difficulty of giving
a proper identity to these people
because it's also a sign of an identity
crisis turning to that kind of ideology
it's not even religion it's an ideology
and that shows that it is indeed a
dimension we no one has taken into
account not only our politicians that
we're going to come back I wanted
somebody to push back on the basic case
Douglas made right at the beginning or
just a moment ago rather that somehow
this is a problem that is it brought
into Europe by I presume those Uggs
means the immigration of most
in big numbers there's there's no doubt
that when you look at the Muslim world
in general there are lots of problems we
have enormous problems with regards to
women's rights LGBT rights freedom of
speech human rights and we got lots of
things that we should be criticizing and
we are criticizing but it would also be
a very big mistake to think that the
Muslim world is a monolithic hold and
that all Muslims are similar and they
have a similar worldview in fact they
are not there are enormous differences
there always were historically and today
as well depending on whom you talk to
which country what time you are focusing
on the differences are amazing my worry
is extremists in one place are creating
more extremists elsewhere whether we
like it or not we're all far too
globalized to think that by closing our
doors and surrounding ourselves by walls
we will be safe and away and removed
from all these problems we want where
all of all of our seniors together it is
a massive terrorism is a big
international global problem and it can
only be solved through global solidarity
with regards to the bikini ban in France
I sincerely believe it was very very
wrong it was a big mistake I think we
should be criticizing faith-based
schools we should be criticizing
extremists preachers we should
definitely monitor what people are
saying in the mosques but for God's sake
chasing women who are just wearing their
bikinis in there and the beach that is
not the way forward but it's even more
dangerous because what's happening is
and this is not what what we perhaps are
not aware of much those pictures do
remember the picture of one lady wearing
a bikini in France and three French
policemen by her
unfortunately that very photograph has
been circulated in Turkey in Jordan in
Egypt with awful caption saying you see
this is what their will say our women
all staged here the Guinea crew both of
our leaders all things because they
danger in the
Nan's address the same way with a bikini
night and you allow them to dress like
that why do you go after crazy tonight
8:00 tonight with a lot written what did
you make it okay and if I cut you off
people sorry I come from a country
because Turkey and France have lots of
similarities they lace today we have
borrowed directly from France not the
anglo-saxon secularism and Turkey has
applied the headscarf bomb Iran has
applied the headscarf man it didn't work
it created massive problems but yes we
all share the same aims with regards to
how do we prevent extremism how do we
prevent terrorism but let's also find
more progressive ways forward
presidential wing women or propellant
rockets butter first of all sorry Alice
but the Burkina ban is a massive
diversion a massive diversion it was a
big mistake for the French state when
that happened I agree but this is not
the biggest issue the biggest issue is
it just up the road again a few days ago
three men with machete went through
London Street hacking at people saying
this is for Allah okay
that child problem and this is always
the way with it we always have
diversions and some of these they're
versions we bring upon ourselves but let
me just get back to the main point we
have had historically massive issues in
Europe nobody who knows anything about
our history wouldn't pretend that but
this is a civil war within a religion
which was not our war and it has become
our war it has become our war and Ellis
you are right and wrong you are totally
wrong to say that there isn't some
agreement on this if you are a Muslim
and you follow Islam you believe that
the Koran came from God and you believe
that what is in it is at least very hard
to run against and so now we have a
situation in in a country like this one
where actually the majority of British
Muslims want being gay like I am to be
made illegal now okay so we had a nice
liberal agreement in recent decades over
being gay and now you import a community
which actually thinks not just that
they're not on board with gay marriage
but they think it should be bade a lock
up a bull offense where does that come
from it comes from Islam okay and where
is it where does the where do all these
make up they come to me and I'm sorry
but it is a much worse problem than we
think
okay one poll last year showed the 50
percent of British Muslims would not go
to the police if they knew somebody
involved in Isis like group was around
them another poll showed two-thirds of
British wasn't saying they would not go
to the police if they knew somebody
involved in extremist activity what the
hell are we doing what the hell are we
doing in ignoring that okay Duggars
heavy
I know I know Ellie hi I just know I
will I'm going to let you come back I
would just want to press covers on the
question because I want to know if we
accept what you said and so obviously a
lot of people in this room do and I
think quite a lot don't I want to know
what you do with this sentiment because
you have just described a difference
with not just the people who went on a
murderous rampage in Borough Market but
with Britain's entire Muslim community 2
or 3 million people so what are you
actually practically saying but saying
that this is a faith that didn't exist
here before therefore a problem that
didn't exist at all
are you suggesting these 2 or 3 million
British citizens somehow have to now
leave the canal of course not
of course so what are you suggesting the
first thing is you admit this issue and
you slow down or stop the flow the
obvious thing if you've got a problem
admit to it and flow the flow ok the
second thing is obviously you try to
work on the people you have here
obviously you can't work on me well you
hope that over many many generations
things will change of course the problem
we all have is a situation like the case
of salman a baby this country gave his
parents asylum they fled from Libya we
gave his parents asylum or now we're
working out what his parents actually
believed but actually then two weeks ago
their son goes into a Manchester Arena
and blows up 22 people one for every
year of life this country gave him so we
could be in a situation where we're
saying okay the first generation are
fine but we've no idea what their chills
are going to do and I would very quickly
make this point really if you want to
see the depth of this problem and a
possible solution see who the most
vilified people in the Muslim community
in this country they are the Reformers
every single case it's the reformer okay
and one one of the one of the one of the
London Bridge attackers one of the
London Bridge attackers last year
attacked an imam who is a friend of mine
in London okay everybody knows this the
Reformers won the bond on the on the
edge of this and that this is the point
okay the Reformers may lose and that
used to be a big tragedy for the Islamic
world and now it's a tragedy for Britain
okay and he wants to come in and we're
going to question
click listen to me and then we must say
from our gift I think it's really unfair
I mean what what makes us think that all
of us all of us we are incredibly
worried about what's happening and I
believe all of us want to find a
solution forward it's only how we're
going to find a solution that's what we
are debating I never said that you know
this was this was not an essential thing
I moved to England and maybe you know
when you are an outsider when you are a
late comer you appreciate it even more
you love it even more
so that's a different thing but what I'm
trying to say is we as we're so used to
having these debates but on both sides
of the Atlantic when you bring one
speaker who criticizes Islam and then
another speaker who defend Islam and
they keep fighting and wailing I've
never liked that I never wanted to be
part of that I'm not even a believer
myself you know but I'm someone who's
interested in in in dialog in peace in
faith and I do note that the way forward
is not by generalizing communities the
biggest problem we have today is how do
we communicate with people who are not
necessarily in this room how do we find
the same language how do we reach out to
girls boys who do yes some of them come
from conservative families and yes
indeed we must stop these fanatics
extremists but if in doing so we
generalize all Muslims I'm very worried
that we're adding fuel to the fire and
generalizing a very specific thing
let's call today that's call today let's
begin to hear some questions and
reactions from all of you I'm hoping
there are people with microphones and
there's one over there so keep your hand
up there keep it up to the lady they can
go and your guest to the one there
that's good let's get a third one lined
up if you Lindy and read the t-shirt
there I'm hoping she's for the language
is walking across purposefully okay
they're not they're good we'll begin
over here my question is and what is the
role of Technology and the internet with
all of this because it seems there is a
parallel timeframe for the last 10 15
years with social media and
multimedia coming into the forefront of
everybody's lives and correlating with
the rise of terrorism and all of these
questions thank you and the question
here yeah and there's clearly a threat
of people going to Zaire and then coming
back and where do you stand on what
should happen there
thank you very specific one and then
we'll hear from you there yeah yeah
hello I'm a two-fold question one is
about identity I think like I'm from
Germany and coming to an abort country I
learned a lot about my own identity if
you have nothing to compare your own
identity with how do you really know
your own identity and I want to make a
second point in Germany over 800,000
refugees came we didn't know who those
people are people welcomed them people
really really engaged into the community
helped and they still do there's a small
royalty which is really loud and it's
complaining about them and there's a
huge majority would really help and
engages the closure which is to
integrate them so what do you think
about that when you talk about those
huge flows of immigrants into England
because I can't see them
don't put the microphone back you just
said I want to ask you a question and
all those million refugees that Germany
very famously welcomed if heaven forbid
but if one of them even was later
involved in an act of terrorism in the
in I know I just wanted because we have
the case obviously that has happened but
I'm just interested in because of what
Douglass said about the case of somebody
Salman the baby who was granted asylum
in this country and then went on to kill
does that change your view of the
million who have been welcomed I don't
think so because all the hundreds of
thousands of troops came fifty years ago
and nothing really much happened so if
there's one it's one person out of 1
million ok let's say the thank you for
that let's see if the question is fair
and I think you've got a microphone up
there oh no you haven't
no you have okay and that's plenty - oh
you've got on it ok we'll hear one more
and then we're going to bring it back
here
got a question hello got a question for
Douglas you talked about wanting to to
stop the flow Douglas do you support a
religious test for immigrants coming to
Europe or Great Britain okay thank you
why don't we start first of all with
this point about the technology and the
internet I'm going to look to you to
this Luigi because it's obviously paid a
big part in driving populism I would've
thought because of automation and
putting people out of work but do you
think it's played and what role is it
played in the spread of terror I think
that technology is always used by
criminals to become sort of a more
sophisticated than the police has to
catch up I think that in I don't think
that the internet Percy is any different
than a lot of Technology that there have
been introduced and I think that we need
to pay some costs in order to add the
police monitor the situation and trying
to catch them early on I think that a
lot of people got upset for the NSA
spying cetera but that some monitoring
is necessary for checking so for example
to resumes is that the encryption that
you have with some messaging services
what fact for example has to end because
it enables terrorists to talk to each
other without any possibility of
monitoring the conversation where would
you be on something like that I'm not an
expert on the details but I think that
it is a bit dangerous to guarantee
completely encryption another dimension
is this is for terrorists but also for
other criminals in Italy we we have
fewer terrorists but a lot of mafia is
not any better yeah people who call a
you write your book refuge you heard the
testimony of somebody from Germany there
who the most famous sort of refugee
movement of recent years a million
arriving there what does it do to your
attitude but also to public attitudes
about refugees if even one out of a
million then goes on to kill and maim as
we saw in Manchester as is it making our
whole attitude to to refuge change I
think and I think this German decision
of the moment
was was truly unfortunate because what
it's done is turn people around across
Europe including Germany instead of
looking at refugees and feeling
compassion a look at refugees and feel
fear that's a disaster
and of course rapidly became completely
unpopular in Germany which is why
Chancellor Merkel inmigrants slammed the
door that within within months within
months right and not only slammed the
door but then did a deal with your great
leader and to ship them back so this is
not noble but the real reason why it was
really unfortunate apart from this
business of turning the biggest asset of
refugees the compassion we should feel
for them in to interfere the biggest
problem is that it was a really foolish
thing to do
this is ten million displaced Syrians
and most of them have fed into the
neighboring countries Turkey Jordan I've
been working with the Jordanian
government last three years and what
those refugees want is the restoration
of normality they want jobs they want
autonomy they they very few only tiny
minority go to the refugee camps because
there it's this model of you feed you
shelter for free forever what people do
is go to the towns to work and the big
tragedy is nobody's brought work Germany
was in a wonderful position to bring
jobs to refugees instead it basically
had this model if you can swim to
Germany fast enough will they do him so
that produced a lot of people who
drowned because there was no mechanism
of getting them there but even on top of
that it was incredibly selective I
reckon that about less than 5% of
Syrians in Germany but something between
a third and a half of all Syrians with
university degrees
in Germany they're the very people who
will be needed to Reno's area although
it may actually help them but the you
know they they may and may baby after
Syria but they may end up with the best
and the brightest arriving and that
would be selfish not noble maybe let's
hear from you Ellie on this question I
know you've got something else to say
but would people people asked about the
question asked about the issue of people
it was from here who come gone to Syria
and they want to come back and obviously
many of those from who left home he went
through Turkey to get to Syria what
should be the policy now not just in
Britain big number European countries
for the so-called returners from those
countries now I see it as a massive
problem and I'm just appalled that
especially with the London Bridge
attacks these people were not hiding
what they were what they believed in it
was so obvious because they like the
propaganda they like to boast and still
it wasn't or it couldn't be chased to me
it's a big problem certainly those who
go to Syria mostly to Syria but to other
countries as well where they are more
radicalized even I think it should be
monitored and I am with you there are
lots of big Internet companies that need
to change their attitude from now on
because this is the world we are living
in with regards to the refugees yes I
mean europe's position in general he
used position i should say sorry i don't
think it is sustainable at all because
most of the refugees as they pointed out
have been divided out sourced in a way
trying to outsource the problem to
Turkey to Jordan and to Lebanon several
times Jordanian government said you know
we can't do it anymore it's not
sustainable in Turkey we have close to
three million refugees Syrian refugees
it's a big mess right now on
humanitarian grounds it's wonderful that
of course Turkey welcomed them but we
have big big problems from security to
gender issues that we don't talk about
and also I think it is not admirable at
all that EU for a long time postponed
talking about freedom of speech
violations in Turkey human rights
violations in Turkey because it was like
part of the barter not to talk about
these issues that's that
you know you lose that's how you lose
respect but I just want to add this
because it never makes it makes the
headlines we have a big problem with
child brides you rightly so mention
those early and right child brides in
Turkey the number of child brides
increase dramatically after Syrian
refugees we already had one in for every
four marriage in wages in Turkey was
with child brides but now even the
numbers increase the number of Turkish
men marrying Syrian girls women as the
second wives third wives increase
polygamy so these issues we don't talk
about but also it's important to notice
because of the entire mess because of
the dangers of the journey most of the
refugees who could make it to Europe are
men young men within a certain age
bracket this is so much so that in
Sweden in places countries like Sweden
it even affected the gender ratio okay
thank you
question was put to Douglas I think
prompted Douglas by your remark that the
one thing you must do to stop or reduce
the flow therefore the questioner asked
do you support a religious test for
immigrants to this country and I suppose
what was in his mind was if you don't
how else would you be able to reduce the
flow first of all of course you've got
to remember that we've been talking
about asylum a lot and certainly now the
people coming into southern Europe
certainly Italian points of entry I'm
not asylum seekers in the way that we've
seen they're not Syrians there are
economic migrants looking for a better
life and that is always in recent years
been a massive part of this and these
two things are constantly elided
deliberately elided I think dangerously
elided so yes I could well get on board
with a religious test for instance in
recent years there has been a
significant genocide on our continent on
our planet further Yazidis who were
almost wiped out a couple years ago I
could certainly get on board with
something that prioritized asylum
seekers as their you CDs or Coptic
Christians that and that I can see what
you're doing I can see what you're doing
that everything's good what I'm saying
is would you want to religious they
didn't prioritize diseases make everyone
find a level but would actually it rule
out and rule
and Muslims from granting entry into the
sky can't see the sense in keeping a
high level of economic migration from
the Muslim world no so yeah a religious
festival yes we're making and secondly
very quickly a gentleman the back from
Germany and you first what it's not a
kids not the case that it's been fine
with Turkish migration since the gas the
bita period Merkel herself said in 2010
that it has been a disaster than five
years later she made the disaster far
bigger but it you know in 2008 Edwyn
went to Germany and spoke to tens of
thousands of Turks in Europe from the
Netherlands Belgium and Germany and said
in a massive public rally do not
integrate but get involved in politics
because we need you i sorry this is
subversion this is outright subversion
who the European democracy so yes we had
a problem and as for the as it were
would it matter if one in 1 million
became a suicide bomber again it's a
cost-benefit analysis isn't it
do as long as you're not the one
standing outside the wine bar in Ansbach
when the suicide bomber goes off it
might be ok for you it might be it might
be ok and it seems to be for most people
in our political parties in Britain it
might be ok for you to not not worry
about this identity question not worry
about the numbers and but you've just
got to hope your kids don't like ariana
grande and go on the wrong night
but I think there's a cost-benefit
analysis that this has to be weighed up
and if you do think that then say it
ok we'll take a suicide bombing every
now and then we'll take the stabbings
every now and then
sure Christie wants to come back and
then I want to another idea just to
remind though that most terrorist
attacks that have happened in this
country as well as in France have been
committed by our citizens by people
having British or French or Belgian
citizenship but that's again the issue
how come our societies have not been
able to cope with the
generation of young people who have been
through our schools have benefited from
our education have been taught to share
our values and still turn to that
murderous ideology we won't interfere on
to the request request again an issue of
identity that somehow we haven't been
able to give them an identity which they
can share into okay it's a it's an
ideology even more so than a religious
issue and unfortunately in this case
Islam is contaminated with that
particular ideology okay
let them hear some see some more hands
because there's lots of people I'm sure
good lots of people who want to express
themselves let them bring Jim come there
and say you got somebody there and have
you got somebody there okay well and
we'll probably I know lots of hands
we're not going to be able to eat you
all but I'll do my best
yes but if we how has our foreign policy
contributed to the problems we're facing
today
good thank you could you bring the mic
French of this gentleman here in
readiness
Mima will go to there yep over there
yep I can ask the same question okay
we'll go to whoever sorry and we'll go
to general in the front our title is
Europe on the edge and as you said in
your introduction a lot has changed
since this title was given the European
project has developed from six countries
to 28 countries with a single market
with a single currency yeah is the cause
of the problem of being on the edge this
drive towards a single state which would
result possibly in all countries
citizens losing their identity okay it's
away from the terrorism topic but
absolutely on our bigger theme yes
you've got a question here I'll talk a
lot about migration coming from the
Middle East but there seems to be an
enormous amount of migration coming from
Africa
can the panel because some ideas of what
they thought we should do because it
seems countries are losing a lot of
their young men and they're all coming
to Europe okay so you're meaning from
your worry is for Africa's sake about
losing their own people is it what the
world view should do okay we got
somebody over there yeah well referring
to the idea that this problem was
imported actually the UK has a colonial
path and in several occasions has
invited immigration in order to rebuild
the country after the war so it's not
it's a bit unfair to say that
inconvenient times we welcome immigrants
and then we shut our doors thank you
so those people are going there with
microphones do you make sure we get a
balance to mix of men and women because
they're quite a few from member we'll
get from here you've got somebody daddy
yeah yes I'm wondering if you know can
talk about why the Scandinavian
countries are consistently scoring as
the happiest places on earth what a
cheery question to lighten the gloom
you've got something there yeah and my
question was we are possibly likely to
have a government when it comes in that
they say that we need to have reduced
freedoms in order to reduce terrorism is
it worth it
thank you I'm going to take two more
then we're going to have sev answers and
closing remarks I'm afraid so we'll have
two more you've been very patient of
young men here he's got his armor but
you've been beaten to it by this man
he's can do one and he'll pass it to you
got that maybe it'll appear what to
manage the panel are very keen on
enthuses more culture and device
diversity etc six took Britain as an
example particularly those northern
towns and focusing purely on culture
what aspects of Saudi Arabia Somalia and
Afghanistan's culture would the panel
like to see more of this misted for
Britain
okay and you call from Agron here yeah
yeah and seeing us the panel are all
being expected to have an opinion on it
on on Islam I just like to know how to
pinterest how many the panel have
studied the Quran the hadith from the
life of Muhammad in detail please okay
that's okay we'll do 1 1 1 this will be
the very last one here ok I'm not doing
much my gender balance record that ok
I'll allow you in any way
God well do British an Israeli citizen
my concern in seeing things up in the
past is how the impact of extremist
violence is going to affect elections
especially coming in next couple of days
here and I'm wondering what a panel sees
our walk and firmly seeing like okay
well there's lots there thank I'm sorry
people I couldn't get in we are
beginning to run outside and I want to
give our panel a chance to react to some
of those questions and make some closing
remarks as well and why don't we begin
with well Paula Collier I'm going to ask
you to tackle the one question that came
up that wasn't really about the
terrorism issue they took aspect to our
biggest subject about Europe and to what
extent your of Ian project was in
trouble and on the edge because of this
insistence as the questioner saw on
driving towards a single European state
I mean for Britain this argument was
rehearsed very strongly a year ago and
it was settled one very clear way but
obviously the question who feels it's
ongoing for the rest of Europe why don't
you take that question pool and any
other closing thoughts you might have
I think the the European project is a is
a is a fantasy of old men who are
fighting an old battle and they're
trying to stop Germany and France having
another war and Germany and France
they're not going to have another war I
mean here's the to my mind the acid test
Norway is not in the euro it's not even
in the European Union and the
Netherlands is in both if we go back to
the 1940s Germany invaded both of them
is Germany now more likely to invade
no way in the Netherlands right
obviously the answer is no right the
piece that's descended on Europe is
nothing to do with this damp institution
all right the institution was because of
a revolt against war so the cultural
shift
Preedy created the institution not the
institution the cultural shift
I think the attempt by these old guys to
create a supranational set of
institutions without any chance of
getting a supranational identity and
it's going to is going to fail big time
I think and I work a lot on societies
where the structure of power has
diverged from the structure of identity
most of society if I work on identities
local and power is highly centralized
and power doesn't turn into Authority
and then you've got a real problem very
in Europe power hasn't turned into
authority the directives of the European
Commission when they're inconvenient so
just ignored product thank you I wanted
to put you one other thing just because
it strikes me that you may be best
placed on Thurs the question that came
from over there was about the extent to
which Britain in a way if you think this
is now a problem
it only has itself to blame in big
quotation marks because of the
invitation to populations that were
previously ruled as colonies by Britain
to come here as immigrants and the
question said in partly to repair and
rebuild the country after the war and so
there is there's a history to this
decision it wasn't as if you know Muslim
communities from Pakistan etc just came
here randomly there was a colonial
history to this sorry but the the the
big surgeon immigration has been the
last 20 years we weren't rebuilding in a
country last 20 years I'm sorry so it
was a big change of immigration policy
which created quite a problem okay and
the idea that this idea that it's
British foreign policies has caused the
problem the effort I want mainly on
Africa but always always Europe in the
last vestiges of neocolonialism
is that whatever happened
in the world it's because of something
we've done we're obsessed but and just
look at just look at the massive
variation across Europe in attribute the
Iraq war and what-have-you and you look
where the Terrorism has been Sweden
Norway Germany France Spain yeah this is
nothing to do with British foreign
policy I'm sorry okay thank you
Ellie why don't you tackle that question
the questioner asks how has foreign
policy what role it has foreign policy
has played in the creation as a driver
of terrorism why don't you take that one
and also anything that composing
thoughts you might have I think we need
to highlight there is there is a clash
obviously but this is not a clash
between civilizations it's not a clash
between religions it is a clash within
nations within every nation there are
conflicting clashing values there is one
big such clash in Turkey in the Middle
East within Europe was as well and
they're all connected we need to be
aware of history I think memory is
important memory is a responsibility I
disagree I think there was a reason why
the entire journey of EU started in the
first place and yes the Brussels elite
did make lots of mistakes but it's
possible to reform EU let's not take
things for granted that easily it's
thought that the journey started most
necessary as a financial project but
this is let us not forget upon the ruins
of the Second World War people who were
very much aware of the dangers of
nationalism jingoism militarism maybe it
won't come from Germany but maybe it
will come from Russia maybe it will come
from somewhere else but that danger is
already there we're not necessarily
going forward sometimes we make the same
mistakes that our ancestors have made to
me it's very important to understand
that we are all of us in this together
the more we create us versus them the
bigger the mess immigration is a two-way
Road when I look at the Turks and Kurds
in Germany yes as a woman
with liberal values it bothers me that
there's so much nationalism so much
religiosity so much sexism among some of
the some of the Turkish and Kurdish
communities but I'm also aware that I
cannot generalize I'm also aware that
they have contributed enormously but
just to give you an example because you
mentioned Ardoin our glance of this
world create his wielders of this world
and vice versa they keep seeing each
other
so when Ardoin gave that speech to the
turks in the netherlands
it was a huge in my opinion mistake but
that also benefits here to this and it's
popular parties just one final example
when you look at how the Turks and Kurds
across Europe voted it's very
interesting 70 percent of the Turks in
Germany voted Pro Ardoin 72 percent of
Turks in the Netherlands watered for
Aragon in the UK 80 percent voted
against Iran just even this example
shows us the diversity within immigrant
communities even within the Turkish
community let alone the entire Muslim
world let us please not make sweeping
generalizations about an ethnicity or
religion or race
three of you three of you still to speak
and I know that we are holding people
later than we expected and people have
dinner reservations and the like so I'm
going to gallop through please now that
you know that you've got to be brief
Cristina cretin this question to you was
the one about reducing freedom in order
to enhance security is it worth it well
I think we live in contradictions on the
one hand we ask for better protection on
the other hand we want our freedoms it
is obvious that the technological
revolution that we've all been addicted
to has had has added to the danger
because obviously all these terrorists
are as good or even better than most of
us at using the same technologies and
I'm not sure at all that even if the gas
follow these big American companies
would agree and subscribe to their own
government requests I'm not even sure
they would be able to control the
contents so I'm afraid this is another
dimension
I think our liberties will be reduced
I'm not sure that it will eventually
work all that well but again it is a
contradiction in our democracy in France
we have been living in a state of
emergency for more than 16 months now
we've become used to having a happy
proficiency has it made you safer well
it seems that many terrorist attacks
have indeed been prevented right but one
terrorist attack is always one too many
of course
okay to go to view left I want you to
luigi's hard to ask you this because
you're not what actually I'm going to
get Douglas next because I want you to
have the last word don't Douglas to you
the question will terror affect these
elections because you know other
countries have had experience of terror
attacks during election campaigns do you
think the ones that
happened in this country will affect the
outcome on Thursday and perhaps we'll
take that if everything else on strap-on
and no I don't think that I mean I will
be very surprised if in the wake of
increased terror attacks the British
people thought it was best to put their
security in the hands as mr corbyn there
huh so that means you can go to mouth
very quickly well there have only been
two groups of people in recent years who
tried to blow up the British people the
IRA and Islamist and one of the very few
things that that linked them is the
support of mr. Corbyn and I hope the
British people will make their voice
heard on that very quickly they let all
of this stuff it's part of what the
point of my book is to try to look at
the deeper things underneath this our
continent is wracked by guilt its racked
by tiredness existential exhaust in a
whole range of things that mean we are
very vulnerable to anyone who comes
along and said it's our fault we're very
vulnerable to it and we I have to say a
high time we've snapped out of it when I
was last on the Greek islands the
reception islands of the camps where
migrants are coming in you know I was
speaking to people from such a wide
range of countries Bangladesh for
instance what's this country done to
bangladesh recently that should be a
reason for us to be continuing to take
in people from that country and what's
your solution if people who think that
you can't solve Syria what are you going
to do to solve Eritrea and you think
that in the meantime we have to continue
the current wave of migration it's
madness very quickly to the Scandinavian
countries I don't buy it all happiness
studies are bunk total but they always
say that the best thing to be is a hill
farmer in Bhutan rubbish absolute
rubbish and it's the same with
Scandinavia you've heard so many
different points the one about the
migration from Africa what aspects of
the culture of Saudi and Somalia we
might want to learn from but why do you
give us a closing thought about where
all this is going
first of all I have to reveal a conflict
of interest I'm an immigrant M&E we ran
in the United States that I'm a name
again so I'm naturally sympathized with
immigrants
and to the struggle there and to the
richness that I bring this said I also
understand the difficulties of
integration I think that when
immigration is too big is not an
immigration is invasion and people feel
overall and overtaken by by different
values and this is not because is Muslim
and non-muslim I think the calculate
versus Protestant can be sort of people
who eat rice versus people with pasta I
think that people value their culture
identities and yes food is a huge part
of the cultural identity and they feel
over overtaken so I think that we should
be a little bit more carefully managing
the process to avoid the backlash that
we observe today but this backlash I
think that I really don't like what the
dark side and identifying Muslim because
I think that is not a calculation but I
think in this country more people died
of Catholic terrorists than of Muslim
parents and in spite of that you don't
have the same level of anger versus
catalysis so I think that is not and I
grew up in a country where there was
political terrorists and I can assure
you was not any better and was all gone
and so I think that we need to realize
that when there are economic problems
ideological problems there is the risk
of extremists and we need to deal with
that and dealing with that is not by
criminalizing a religion or cumuli zhing
a group on the other end we need the
support of that group one way in which
Italian Hong Kong terrorists was
commonly status was was beaten the time
is because the then Communist Party
basically isolated the toilet so I think
that what you need to do is trying to
bring closer the Islamic community and
make sure that they isolate the few bad
apples thank you
very well it's no surprise duranium we
have not perhaps reached a consensus we
have certainly not resolved these huge
issues we've generated a lot of heat but
I think in the process also I think some
light I hope it's been illuminating for
all of you please
will you I hope join me in thanking a
very very important panel Paul Collier
electrified the ridges and galas 15o
friends and Douglas Murray thank you all
very much thank you